there's lots of different ways to talk
about and to notate differentiation
which is this process we're going
through finding the gradient function
spec even there I'm throwing out a lot
of words at you so I'm gonna I'll try
and break down a lot of these terms so
you've got all in one place so when you
see it said different ways you don't get
too confused okay so let's start right
you'll see this if event is a vector
function right okay
then f dash X right I say that is f dash
X okay well just f dash right
what that means is tell me the gradient
function which we've been finding my
first principles okay another name for
the gradient function you might have
heard me say a few times is the
derivative okay because it comes from
that function so it repeats is derived
from however just to make things more
confusing for you okay the process of
going from F to its derivative okay
this process is not called deriving
mathematicians in their use of English
it's called differentiating
okay so to go from a function to its
gradient function to go from F to F - we
call that differentiate okay now all of
this is in terms of F's okay usually
when you get a function we say Y is
equal to something right like say y
equals x squared okay so this is again
that's a function right but when you
want to talk about its gradient function
there's another way because isn't of
describing there's an X here right so
what would I say
gradient is all about rise over run rise
over run okay so therefore our gradient
right is rise over run look up at this
one because this is important okay rise
is really just a way of saying how is my
vertical distance changing how is my Y
value changing right so rise instead of
saying that I could say the change in Y
divided by the change in X okay but this
is very long so it stays instead of
saying change in we say D actually if we
mean Delta like Greek letter you see
this in science as well in like a
chemical equation you've got some
chemicals and then they turn into
something else and there's a reaction a
change in the middle right that's just
the capital D ingredient they'll talk
okay so a change in Y we say we call
that dy okay and the change in X we call
DX so this is another way of saying the
gradient function or the derivative okay
it's the same thing but let's make this
a little more right this wine right it's
actually equal to something in terms of
X okay so I can write this as putting
that wine out over here so Y is the
function I am differentiating okay and D
on DX is the process of getting the
gradient function differentiate okay so
it's a bit like you know when you see
sine of 30 degrees
okay thirty degrees is the thing that
you're doing an operation on and sign is
the operation okay well if you want to
differentiate why you put a D on T X at
the front okay so for instance I could
write D 1 DX of x squared that would
mean differentiate x squared okay now
there's a really crucial because lots
people make this mistake I know I did
back when I was in year 11 when you try
to work out the the different derivative
of something and just writing down your
answer okay the question says you know
differentiate or find the gradient
function and then you got a whole bunch
of examples right okay and say the third
one is x squared okay so you get down to
writing your answer and you say well the
way to write a derivative is this right
so you're right D on DX right it's
better than saying dy over DX because
there isn't it Y right but also it
doesn't make sense on its own it would
be like saying sign on its learn sign of
what
it's an operator has to do something to
something there has to be an object Y
all right so you have to really say do
DX all your function okay strictly
speaking when you've just got the one
term you don't but we put them into
clarify so hmm one more thing I wanna
put down when you're finding the
gradient function often they don't want
the function actually the green in a
particular point okay so for instance if
I want the gradient at X equal zero okay
instinct instead of saying if that X
they'll say f dash zero that means
what's the gradient when X is zero
okay it's all these different ways to
write things okay you want to be
watchful for them and even though we've
all been talking in terms of y's and x's
in a sense it doesn't really matter what
letters to use right services you could
have like a you know a let's see a
position function in terms of say your
velocity position velocity okay I can
still find the grading function of this
I can still differentiate but it won't
be do and yet okay what be do you wanna
yes it'll be D P that's the thing at the
front right all I'm D but what's the
other variable D be okay
and that'll be 60 okay so what we're
doing fiea vs. will be doing TIA
let's see here you're differentiating
expert here with respect to X X is the
UM the variable you're paying attention
to here I'm differentiating P with
respect to Vista there's no exiting yeah
right I'm differentiating with respect
to different letter of different
variable in this case B sometimes you
see that this abbreviated to this
because people get secret writing with
respect to okay but there you go
I admit that's very confusing there's so
many different ways of writing it the
reason why there's so many ways to write
it is because lots of different kinds of
people mathematicians scientists
engineers sometimes oh it's on they all
want to use this same idea but in all
the different fields they write things
differently okay so therefore you've got
different notation that comes up because